while younger viewers might not question
the events of the scorpion king
there are a slew of things that only
adults will notice while watching
we're here to take a look at them while
most of mathias's companions opt for the
machismo of horseback
our titular character is much more fond
of his trusty camel
he claims this particular mount is
smarter than its equine counterpart and
he may be onto something because the
camel's location is always remarkably
convenient
even over the roar of battle matthias's
whistle sails across the winds to his
camel's ears
by the third time we witness this
beckoning we start to question the
validity of the logistics involved here
camels might have good hearing and sure
maybe mathias is on to something when he
claims they're smarter than horses
but even so the film stretches credulity
to its
limits towards the end of the film it
becomes harder to chalk it up to a smart
travel companion instead of
lazy scriptwriting machismo is a major
part of the action genre but the
scorpion king takes it to an extreme
take cassandra's introduction not only
is she scantily clad
she goes weak in the knees upon seeing
mathias listen
it's the rock we get it but let's ease
up on the longing eye contact and we
really aren't sure why cassandra needs
to straddle matthias in order to heal
him
once matthias stumbles into memnon's
harem and is swarmed by an army of
thirsty concubines our eyes start to
roll into the backs of our skulls
adolescents might be entranced but
adults may begin to wonder why
every woman in ancient egypt looks like
an la model
a lack of hydration in an impoverished
desert environment
does wonders for your figure apparently
this overbearing machismo is also
evident in some of the film's most
ludicrous action scenes somehow matthias
transforms into a ninja in a random cave
and
systematically picks off a group of
soldiers
to witness what the future holds would
be a magnificent weapon for a military
leader to possess
that's the logic behind memnon's
domination of his adversaries
cassandra a powerful sorceress is able
to predict his battle's outcomes
as such memnod keeps her by his side
throughout his conquests
she does appear to actually have said
powers and we do indeed see them put on
display
as far as utilizing those powers though
she appears
quite inept any time memnon calls on her
to inform him of what the future holds
she
stumbles through her mental pathways to
arrive at a monosyllabic response
it's either good or bad no more detail
than that folks how
magical the sorceress also doesn't
appear to be able to properly read her
visions rendering
some of her predictions like the one
regarding mathias's demise
outright wrong an arrow in his back does
nothing to slow his pursuit of vengeance
witness the glory as he rips the
projectile from his bulging muscles and
uses it to launch his nemesis into a
giant
ball of fire where was that in your
vision cassandra
her powers might be impressive but as
she has little talent for interpreting
her visions with nuance
they're about as likely to backfire as
they are to help
after a scary opening narration explains
memnon's overwhelming power
the story shifts to a gathering of
tribal leaders arguing about the best
way to deal with the tyrant
after king balthazar entertains us by
crushing a snotty brat's hand
mathias steps into the scene it is
explained that he has been
hired to kill memnon sorcerer so that
memnon can be defeated in battle from
this moment on
any adult with an awareness of the
linear progression of time
will see the story's structure unravel
the assassination doesn't go as planned
and mathias is forced to watch memnon
kill his brother
no doubt vengeance is in order the rest
of the film sees mathias try his hardest
to kill the man that he was already
hired to kill except now
he's angry that's pretty much the rest
of the story in a nutshell
this lax plot leaves plenty of wiggle
room for elaborate swordplay
leather lingerie and hordes of baddies
to kill which is what the movie is
really about when all is said and done
the events of the scorpion king take
place in 3077 bc
it also obviously takes place in a
fantasy version of our world so we can
excuse most of its whimsical aspects
it can be hard to skirt vast historical
inaccuracies when they start piling up
though the opening scene of the scorpion
king features a hapless sentinel
receiving a shuriken
straight to the dome not only does this
scene take place long before the
shuriken's creation
but the shuriken is a japanese weapon
originating in
land far beyond the deserts of egypt the
flurry of weapon-based liberties doesn't
stop there going so far as to launch
mathias out of a catapult
to escape his would-be captors worry not
about our hero's demise he lands
comfortably on a scattering of pillows
we can suspend a lot of disbelief if
need be but when it comes to historical
inaccuracies there is only
so much even the most eager grown-up can
take
from the moment we meet him the
tyrannical memnon is presented as a
mighty warrior
narration states that he is the greatest
swordsman the world has ever seen
seeing as that statement is delivered in
the opening moments of the movie we wait
excitedly to see his blade-based prowess
on display
at last a scene in which he is training
with his guards arrives
we feel our excitement brimming this is
it we think he's going to get angry at
the news delivered to him and unleash
his slice and dice fury on these poor
lackeys
it's going to be awesome and then
nothing
there never actually comes a moment when
memnon's legendary swordsmanship is put
on display
even his brief moment of victory in the
final confrontation
doesn't come because of his alleged
skills but because a random guard
walks into the arena and shoots an arrow
into mathias's back
the battle sequences in the scorpion
king are loads of fun
there's plenty of sword clashing arrows
fly everywhere
punches are swung and even some body
slams are thrown in for good measure
there is one impressive action effect
that is reserved solely for the good
guys however
and that is the devastating impact of
their arrows
on numerous occasions the bad guys land
some arrow hits and their targets
fall to the ground but when matthias's
arrows hits their mark
their impact sends his foes into
backwards somersaults it has an almost
slapstick effect we may not be well
versed in the bow and arrow but we
are comfortable saying that this
cartoonish trope has diminishing returns
and it starts to wear on any adult's
enjoyment of the movie
dying young was a lot more common in
ancient times
disease ravaged the land and seeped into
the human body in countless ways
unstopped by modern antibiotics or
hygiene one of the ways these dangerous
germs wormed their way into the fragile
human body was
and still is through our disgusting
mouths
modern dentistry has gone a long way
towards keeping our teeth healthier but
that isn't the case in the scorpion king
in this ancient land pearly whites shine
bright
like every single acadian has a killer
dental plan
maybe we're being jealous the contrast
of the beautiful actors
perfectly tanned bodies against the
whites of their teeth is
admittedly spectacular or perhaps we're
just noticing some particularly
overzealous color correction
whatever the reason it's jarringly
apparent that everyone living in gamora
in 3077 bc
has incredibly great teeth before the
scorpion king was even a concept there
was
the mummy the wildly successful film
demanded a sequel
and hollywood saw to it that audiences
got what they asked for
the people who saw the scorpion king as
a direct result of this viewing marched
into the theater with questions
chief among them how the heck did the
rock turn into a giant scorpion
those looking for interesting answers
and mythos development are drastically
let down by the scorpion king
especially when it comes to how matthias
becomes the titular beast
the process is as it turns out
straightforward and
boring memnon poisons an arrow with
scorpion venom which matthias gets hit
by
later cassandra heals him and proclaims
that he now has the blood of the
scorpion in his veins
the movie chugs along with hardly
another reference to the event at all
this omission seems less a factor of
screen time and more an act of lazy
screenwriting
in the climax of the scorpion king
matthias faces off against memnon
the two duke it out on the balcony of a
temple and appear to be worthy
adversaries trading blows across the
terrace
the sword clashing turns in memnon's
favor when he pulls an ace out of his
tunic
he plunges his blades into a nearby
flame and lights his swords on fire
in that moment an adult viewer will
search their memory for an image of
memnon covering his swords in
any type of flammable substance and come
up empty
we're not sure how much heat is required
to create an open flame on
metal but we're certain it's a
temperature that can't be achieved with
a quick
insert into an open flame during battle
the ordeal is utterly symbolic of the
early 2000s which generally induces
grins rather than scoffing
while the ability to light steel on fire
shouldn't exist we do have to admit that
it looks pretty cool
battle on warriors you can call out to
the scorpion king for its faults all you
want but there is
one thing that can't be denied it
captures
a star being born the only aspect of
this film that rescues it from being an
outrageous act of camp
is the star power of the rock however
there is
something about this rule that seems out
of place
have you guessed what it is he has hair
in this movie
and not just any hair he's got thick jet
black hair that flows
all the way down his back once you key
in on it
you realize it's a bit weird looking and
not just because it's hair attached to
the rock's head the stark hairline of
his wig
which looms above his perfectly plucked
eyebrows makes the rock
look plastic this paired with the fact
that the rock has been
famously bald for years now makes it an
odd look
to encounter today check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one